les infirmières libérales étaient dans
la rue à tour une cinquantaine d'entre
elles se sont rassemblés devant l'hôtel
de ville en début d'après-midi une
protestation pour une meilleure
reconnaissance notamment salariale de
leur travail alors que les médecins ne
viennent d'obtenir qu'un euro 50 de plus
par consultation qu'espère ce
travailleur du secteur paramédical on en
parle avec notre invité Pauline roche
bonjour
vous êtes infirmière libéral lors de la
manifestation cet après-midi on va voir
les images
c'était à tour vous aviez il y avait un
cercueil qui était présent la symbolique
c'est quoi c'est c'est là où va votre
profession oui c'est on peut on peut on
peut faire un raccourci comme celui-là
oui en fait ce qu'on veut imager par le
cercueil c'est qu'effectivement
la profession étant déclin on a vraiment
peur à un moment donné que la les soins
de ville tel qu'on les connaît
disparaissent
d'où la symbolique du cercueil où on va
le faire circuler de alors de ville en
ville de départements départements pour
qu'il atteigne le ministère de la Santé
à l'automne de manière à essayer
d'alerter à la fois nos concitoyens pour
leur dire attention les soins de vie
sont en danger d'alerter aussi nos
collègues qui ne sont pas encore alertés
parce qu'effectivement on est quand même
une profession assez solitaire et aussi
de d'alerter le gouvernement et lui dire
qu'on va pas on va pas arrêter là on a
démarré au mois de décembre mais on
n'est pas solarité il y a un risque sur
l'activité sur les cabinets infirmiers
sur l'activité d'infirmiers ou
infirmières libérale comme vous oui il y
a oui oui il y a un risque certain
raccroche la blouse alors il y en a
beaucoup il y a plus de 30% de nos
collègues qui raccrochent à blues faut
savoir que avant le covid la durée de
vie d'une infirmière c'était 7 ans
après le covid s'est passé à 5 ans c'est
juste dramatique tous les cabinets de
ville sont en manque de
collègues si vous regardez toutes les
annonces il y a beaucoup de manques et
on apprenait récemment en plus que dans
les centres de formation on n'a jamais
vu autant de d'étudiants qui n'allaient
pas au bout de la formation en coloc
c'est quoi le quotidien d'un infirmier
libéral infirmière libérale alors on
commence légalement c'est 7h à savoir
que la plupart d'entre nous commencent
beaucoup plus tôt on a des amplitudes
horaires qui sont généralement de 12 à
14 heures on voit nos patients ensuite
on a entre guillemets une pause on n'est
pas avec nos patients pendant cette
pause là on va faire de la coordination
c'est-à-dire qu'on va rappeler les
médecins on va rappeler par exemple
et toute la partie administrative de nos
patients qui n'est pas visible mais que
l'on fait et ensuite dans 90% des cas on
a aussi une tournée du soir puisque on
est quand même sur une population
vieillissante et dépendante votre
rémunération se fait en fonction des
actes de soins
en plus d'indemnités forfaitaire
indemnités kilométrique c'est tout tout
l'ensemble que vous voulez voir
augmenter parce qu'effectivement au
niveau de nos actes on a une
nomenclature qui est très complexe très
compliqué qu'on veut aussi faire
réévaluer mais il faut savoir que nos
actes n'ont pas été évalués depuis 2009
donc vous êtes payé autant aujourd'hui
qu'en 2009 autant aujourd'hui qu'en 2009
sauf que l'inflation a quand même
explosé et encore plus ces derniers
temps
les médecins libéraux je les médecins
pardon je le disais en introduction on
obtenu 1 euro 50 de revalorisation de
leur actes qu'est-ce que vous espérez
vous aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez
à un moment pouvoir être entendu et bien
on l'espère on espère parce
qu'effectivement sans les infirmiers
libéraux on a mis pas mal de pancartes
que vous voyez à l'affiche
dont certaines où on dit c'est
l'hostoïco parce que les patients qui
sont dépendants à domicile ne coûte pas
si cher que ça à la société parce qu'il
faut parler prix c'est on est dans
l'économie
sauf que si les infirmiers libéraux qui
sont payés à l'acte finissent par
raccrocher la blouse ces gens là vont
finir en EHPAD vont finir dans des
structures hospitalières
ça coûtera beaucoup plus cher à la
société que ne coûte à l'heure actuelle
une infirmière ou un infirmier libérale
merci Pauline roche d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous